poi sarà tutti ragazzi e benvenuto
questo nuovo video sono parigi ha chiuso
il colletto alto perché c'è un cerotto
il titanico quindi copriamo il cerotto
abbiamo fatto un sacco di roba su
playstation fino ad oggi non ho
pubblicato troppi gameplay per non
spoilerare insomma varie cose per adesso
la presenza e uscita quindi ragazzi nel
mentre io mi sono finito totalmente
astros playroom che è meraviglioso tra
l'altro rispetto agli altri play.com
questo poi è veramente fatto benissimo
cos'è questo rumore proviene dai
sotterranei e forse dovresti darci
un'occhiata che questa roba non ce
l'avevo presente vabbè sono io ma dai
c'è una via non l'avevo mai vista cosa
c'è qua sotto
mi scusi che mi dite che c'è qualcosa
sotto non hanno visto che estero ma che
è a rega a buongiorno e picchio tutti
c'è un punti inter sapevo che non ho
idea di che con giuro non so cosa sia
io non volevo fare questo intuito lo
farà tra roba proveniente 1994 ritorno
al 1990 ragazza è ritornato duro c'è una
play uno va bene salve chiude ad ma dai
ma che ne so io ma non potevate fare che
salta di consumo e funzionava
praga cosa stiamo gioca cos'è sta roba
sono sono veramente un po inquietato
prova bene saltando su delle memory card
e tutto giusto e tutto corretto nella
mia testa
questa questi anni sogni che facevo da
bambino se dovesse vincere ovunque
parola quello sbloccata finendo astro
slam ma in realtà vi giuro non volevo
neanche fare questo in questo video
prova niente al check point
quindi c'è una boss battle sicuro nota i
nuclei sis
oddio pensavo sera in crisis mi ero
preso benissimo secondo mente dove
veramente menarli lock stock è
impossibile del carbone o di oddio oddio
ave di coraggio sono le devono aspettare
una volta in più va beh oddio c'è un
poligono t rex che mi vuole uccidere
praga è tutto a posto c'è nel senso
daino crediti sarà anche più difficile
di questo vinte ma belli ed io sono
morto niente sono scarsi scusate ho
preso solo giocatore sbagliato io c'è
ancora una vita adesso mi dovresti
piegare primo con prima ok madonna come
lo schivata stavolta però c'era perfetto
allora l'ho ucciso e fatta
[Musica]
tutto a posto ragazzi si non ballare
così come ecco a poco a posto c'è uno
più grosso sembra colori toy story
questo qua penso sia in 1080p per 9
milano 20 x 1080 corca h
sono vivo per miracolo dai file come
prima no ma ragazzi ma è una boss battle
incredibile salve non ti incazzare che
non ho più vite basta quanta gente non
ho più vite sono morto
e vabbè ali caga lui fuori ok dato non
mi ha ancora colpito non so come in
genere quando di queste cose poi muoio
però fratello veramente non so che c'è
una coppa la coppa nell'occhio
mi sembra giusto
dimmi che non devo fare l'altro occhio
sono l'abbiamo finito ok abbiamo finito
e questo ragazzi rappresenta insomma il
mio percorso scolastico
sono vivo per miracolo gli ho tirato
qualcos'altro nell'occhio per ha
funzionato ho idea ce l'ho fatta la
lingua di kg la lingua no ragazzi è
diventato incredibile stagione tirati
madonna che botta dimmi che sei morto
perché non saprei che altro fare
perfetto non sono al primo tentativo
gelo fatto incredibile che premio mi dai
mi dai un altra playstation 5 che non
già due società può dio ha pensato di
buttare giù a noi sono i titoli di coda
bellissimo no no anche la gente va beh
ma non si può stare tranquilli mai
allora ditelo ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi
ho finito ho staccato una lettera questi
erano i titoli di coda di astros
playroom che sono sacrosanti secondo me
da leggere
bellissimo bellissimo secondo me se
componi tutte le lettere gialle esce
fuori una frase stranissima se noi
ragazzi andiamo nella sfida di rete a
tempo
ci sono un sacco di mini sfide che sono
molto carine che io ho fatto in questa
sono 1.600 esimo nella classifica
mondiale e prima che uscisse la
playstation
ero tipo quinto vogliamo provare a
vedere se riesco a migliorarmi per
quanto la vedo veramente difficile
perché per fare 45 secondi suo livello
ci ho messo un sacco di tempo nel senso
dovuto provare un sacco di volte quindi
proviamoci let's golf
queste ragazze come volevo fare oggi
prima di finire però vabbè ormai lo fa
ho fatto già un bel po di gameplay però
voglio regalarvi se riesco un
miglioramento di del mio tempo record
devo fare tutto sta roba in tempo record
il vero record del mondo e sui 36
secondi e io non ho la più pallida idea
di come sta roba si possa fare in 36
secondi
magia c'è chi l'ha fatta i 36 secondi
era un mago e impulsi cioè non si può
fare a chiarato la playstation non so
come hai fatto
oppure non si può fare in 36 secondi
starò cioè io non ne ho idea sto già
perso tempo un sacco qui non batto
marconi record però va bene meno finisco
perché vorrei provare vedere si è
scoperto di recente
no sono caduto vai uccidimi una volta
che sbagli ti conviene di farlo perché
tanto non batte il record mischione
appena fuori snob john f
noise not gonna happen
porca trova 46 secondi di mortacci ci
riprovo l'ultima volta per vedere se
riesco a migliorare il mio record perché
una roba che effettivamente minimi
trigger a ok questo hanno fatto
benissimo ragazzi
[Musica]
perfetto perfetto
ho fatto tutto qui 43 secondi e punti
ragazzi è incredibile 43 secondi e
fantastico due secondi in meno di
contavo fatto bene più di così
io più di così non so cosa fare non so
come fare come abbiamo fatto a fare 36
ma più di così è impossibile vediamo
quanto quanto sono in classifica 1015
mille quindicesimo in classifica
mondiale 1015 e poi ci sono un sacco di
altre persone che l'hanno fatto prima
voglio vedere il primo 35
come puoi fare 30 c non è possibile come
ha fatto a fare 35 non si può fare cioè
non è non c'è niente che tu possa fare
per fare sette secondi in meno
cosa diavolo è secondo me c'è qualcosa
perché non vedo io
c'è comunque alcun tipo le palme magari
ti danno uno slancio lo so ma c'è
qualcosa che non capite però c'è sicuro
vuoi perché non puoi fare 35 che cacchio
è un'opera un attimo ho pensato potesse
scappare il livello di ciò ma non per
chi non puoi scappare livello comunque
signori questa è la figlia di oggi nel
prossimo video proprio la battere record
e basta noi vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come
non mi piace anche alla risorsa che
cominciò tutto descrizione se non sono
questi iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo
ciao ragazzi
[Musica]